we've been hanging a lot hanging out a
lot recently what's your favorite thing
about her
her left oh that's really cute actually
i feel like she's gonna watch this yeah
hey addison
it's over again for bryce hall and
addison ray
et has learned that bryce allegedly
cheated on addison during a february
trip to las vegas
and the couple has broken up i love you
and i wish
i never did the obsessed singer has
since unfollowed bryce on instagram
though he still follows her
[Music]
the pair's had a roller coaster
relationship they've been on and off
for a while breaking up and reconciling
last year i have to get a little
personal with you the bryce hall
situation
you guys were on and then you were off
and then i don't know if you saw
i talked to him about you yeah i did see
that
let's but what happened
if you can share you know i think
like you said there was a lot of times
we were on we were off and it was kind
of just like a
a confusing situation right now we're
just kind of
both deciding that you know there are a
lot of things going on in both of our
lives that we really need to focus on
and
um and figure out so i think you know
for me i
just really want to focus on my family
my brands my my career and just really
trying to shape
my life for the next five to ten years
and he has to figure out as well and i
wish him the best of luck in it all and
i think
um at the end of the day um we're both
still
you know wishing the best for each other
and i'm still friends
and hopefully you know who knows what'll
happen
in the future i'm kind of just living
life day by day and
um we're still young so i'm really not
not too worried about anything i think
at the end of the day
there's a great plan in store for my
life and if that's
involving bryce or not it's going to be
part of the bigger plan which is
going to be great but this time things
may not be
as friendly in february youtuber
keemstar
claimed to have screenshots of a woman
alleging that she hooked up with bryce
in vegas
at the time bryce took to twitter to
write quote i didn't cheat on addison
when you say that you're obsessed with
me me too
shortly after bryce's tweet addison took
to social media to say she's handling
some things
offline adding quote when and if i want
to share i will make that decision
thank you again for all the love and
support hate is never the answer
earlier this month e.t talked to bryce's
bff josh richards about the situation
what's going on with him in and addison
i know you talked about this on your
podcast a little
bit which is why i'm asking you yeah
yeah no
um i mean for me it's like i'm the wrong
guy to ask right i'm not
in their relationship sadly you know
it's just bryson addison so that's
that's
all for him to speak about and that's
for addison's we got i don't really want
to
i don't want to put words into their
into their relationship or
or anything that they don't want to put
out on the internet you know were you
surprised by the
allegations i mean
i'm not really surprised when i hear any
allegations now on the internet just
because like people are
crazy so they'll throw at the most
offside
or the you know most unbelievable or
detrimental to your career whatever they
there
there's always going to be people doing
that so uh i i tend not to
really believe what i first hear
especially when it comes from
someone i have no idea or a random
source
yeah but he's doing okay right yeah no i
think i think
that uh mentally guys guys doing all
right so
yeah et has reached out to bryce's rep
for comment
you